this man has more projects than he has
fantasy football leagues he is the star
of I hate kids in select theaters and on
demand today as well as I'm sorry season
2 which began premiering earlier this
month and airs every single Wednesday at
10:00 Eastern on truTV good to see you
Tom Everett Scott it's good to see you
too so now you and Chris Brockman my
compadre across the way over there have
a lot in common
handsome well that's super handsome
yes sir Prince Oh athletic no no let me
handle those sorry you went to Syracuse
correct yes what gear did you graduate
ninety-two Chris 2002 okay so that's way
off yeah see you know you can't happen
to any on campus stories from that sort
of no okay 92 was that who was was that
post McNabb was that McNabb was there
you just leave or something like McNabb
left okay gone right it was Bologna I
think there's the coach it's right and
it was the first year for Billy Owens
think Derrick Coleman might have been
like a second good for a basketball
shirt well yeah yeah Sherman Douglas is
last year basketball I think that was
kind of like the end of the of the of
the good football years until recently
right and and it was just the height of
this basketball run it was Bay High man
what does it feel like to watch your
team beat Duke and Cameron Indoor like
they did that was incredible because
that game started off terribly for
Syracuse right I think they started off
oh you know 11 to nothing and that was a
great game I mean big win that had to be
what's it like just tell me what it's
like to beat Duke cuz that's just that's
gotta be something that's pretty it was
pretty awesome I'm not gonna lie I wish
I was there a number one team and not
just any to keep beat the number one
team when they're not Dukes number one
that's got to feel pretty good yeah poor
guy took a charge from Zion and it'll
not help how much money would what would
you require to take a charge from Zion
Williamson running down the court what
would you what would that what's that
price tag guarantee damn you have
children and keep that in writing right
how many kids do you have
I have two okay she's trying to think
what my life insurance policy is a
contact Lloyd's of London and see if
there's an under written sort of thing
for that I mean
my gosh but that's amazing to watch that
sort of thing for congrats on your
Syracuse Orange win right there and now
you root for the Patriots your diehard
Patriot fantasy that's right I grew up
in Massachusetts I'm from East
Bridgewater mass and been a Patriots fan
my whole life where's your accent I
don't know where it went all I can
attribute to is doing lots of theater
going to school in Syracuse around a lot
of upstate New Yorkers right yeah every
once in a while certain words like what
kindergarten October arthritis words I
don't say that often
sounds like a Rorschach test
arthritis like seeing kindergarten the
right way for me hurts hurts a little
bit you know what was for me when I
first started out doing my job
I had a thick New York accent oh really
yeah I did I really did what part of New
York Staten Island New York okay okay so
and it still comes out if you cut me off
in traffic well but the word tournament
it took a lot for me to stop saying
tournament tournament the n-c-double-a
tournament I would go on television sake
tonight in the NCAA tournament and it's
just like no people are like so I had to
literally write down the word and I
would spell it tu RN - Ament turn so I
could just say tournament and I still
have that as a mental yeah exercise yeah
it comes out yeah people will point it
out on set of like you just said that
words so strong I'm like oh no I gotta
work on that it's funny didn't we have
one Matt Damon was on he said chicken
palm out its left palm palm was it just
slipped out it sounded just like it I've
ordered a few chicken palms ticking
palms yeah yeah all right Tom efforts
got here on the rich as a joke you
cannot though I subscribe to the
Patriots is underdog
well Tory line that's being put out
there by the Patriots right now Tom I
don't know I mean you can you really you
mean going to Arrowhead in ten degree
weather they're not an underdog what are
you talking about how they this the
sense that that Brady says everybody
thinks they suck and what what's the
what is what is it no it's tighter it's
right now bet against us I see what
you're saying is they're trying to
generate this
talking about actual line I get it okay
set in the town of in Vegas where Moe
green has no place or signpost by the
way you have been in a movie with Moe
green I have you do yes ask you about
that Saul Siler but you know um you know
what I mean like the whole concept is
like nobody thinks we can do it come on
thinks they can do it everybody knows
they can get from Las Vegas that against
this there it is right there we're
putting it up on the screen I guess
they're looking for any kind of
motivation I think they do realize how
tough it is gonna be to win there I
think they do I mean come on it's
they're not gonna wash in there and
crush them they're not I mean how do you
take away Tyreke L speed it's pretty
tough
see now I I think you're being a very
sensible New England fan right you don't
say you don't have that New England so
do you see so you're such a nice guy Tom
that you can't you don't have that New
England sense of that you're not happy
unless you're unhappy is a sports fan
you don't have that gosh I mean you
well-adjusted just I might be but I
always thought that was the Eagles brand
isn't it like eels fans yeah I just I've
always heard that Massachusetts fans are
really annoying when they win you're not
one of them to the point where you could
sit here and say you know what I hear
about you are the most annoying winner
Chris you are them does that mean
yeah did I stutter have I been in here
bragging for the last four years that
we've been on the show know who dude on
Twitter know in the Patriots won you
were impossible impossible because
everyone said they couldn't do it they
were down twenty eight to three
need I remind you well that was years
ago that was absolutely years ago but
you understand we're putting down right
now picking it up so you don't have that
gene you you don't have that where did
we go so well adjusted I don't know I
think if you catch me at the right
moment I'm probably disappoint you okay
here on the show how many fantasy
football leagues were you in okay this
year I was in five because I dropped one
come on
so I was in six last year and I made the
playoffs in four of them the one that I
did not make the playoffs in you wanted
to win I really wanted to win so badly
what league is that it's the one with
my college friends is the one we've
talked about on the show before it's 24
rounds of the draft you also seen people
Syracuse New England and a draft that
goes on for eight hour thinks about it
for rounds how much time that's what I'm
saying
I mean you have to have stamina that's
why I lost I didn't have stamina during
the 24 rounds yeah
how many roster spots are you gonna
practice squatters by the end how many
teams there's no one left on the waiver
wire it's completely it's yeah it's a
carcass that's imagine totally so you
start two quarterbacks three running
backs four wide receivers tight in
kicker and and then it has this huge
bench
it's so stupid you lost it I lost I
think I came in last Oh No
yeah mm-hmm what's your team name
favorite team name that you were all
year Oh my team name and that is
electric boogaloo okay cuz it's my
second time in the league I dropped out
at one point and then came back so it
was the sequel okay you chose electric
boogaloo break into electric boogaloo
[Laughter]
audience you should have just seen how
you gave me Tom just gave me the look of
like what's my from Bob what's my what
is my malfunction that have all out of
all the true yeah I won I was in for
okay I had I was in as I said four
leagues one with Chris over there in a
charity League run by a Jerry Cantrell
of Alice in Chains we won them so
probably they haven't reached out to us
at all I was actually thinking about
that about the the Victor spoils if you
will that's bad form not yet
I gotta get you know I gotta get on
Jerry and the two other ones were just
leagues that I went on espn.com just
with my kids Oh fun where we just
drafted a 10-7 and a five-year-old and I
want them both one of them where I
inadvertently forgot to delete it and I
auto drafted yes it took that one down
really and then the one I didn't win was
the one with my poker butt
in the worst possible you want to win I
know did you ever think it is that why I
didn't know ever thinking I just ran out
of steam I ran out of luck you know it's
just one of those things where my guys
who were dynamite like alvin kamara the
last two three weeks of the season
wasn't getting the ball and he wasn't
getting in the end zone as you know the
Saints were struggling yeah how do you
see the Super Bowl who's making the
Super Bowl do you think Tom I mean I
think we've already seen one great
version of the Super Bowl earlier in the
regular season when the Chiefs played
the Rams I mean that game was incredible
especially from a fantasy football
aspect great great we were talking about
a greatest game in the history the
fantasy put football era because there
had to be like 12 starters in that game
of the fantasy football game and they
just kept scoring yes so that's what
that would be a great Super Bowl
I think obviously I'm pulling for the
Patriots I would love to see them go
back I you know the only other team I
really root for in the NFL is the Saints
I happen to be in New Orleans visiting
my friend Steve Zahn he was on a show
called Treme and I was just there for
the first time my life in New Orleans
enjoying it it happened to me Super Bowl
weekend they didn't play the game in New
Orleans they played it in Miami but we
watched it in a bar and the roof came
off the pile iterally think the roof
came off the bar and we were marching in
the streets of New Orleans that night it
was such a huge thing that had to be
absolutely amazing so I have a place in
my heart for the Saints sure so I'd love
to see them but the Saints V Patriots
you want to crush them right absolutely
and Steve Zahn it was the best man at
your wedding correct he was okay and did
you ever meet him before that thing you
do that's where you met him that's where
we met we met we talked to the phone on
the phone and then we rehearsed together
with our teachers who taught us how to
play the instruments and it was just a
great night it was really funny we were
just very humiliated by how bad we were
at that point
playing guitar Andrew was the best one
at it actually met me I I was way ahead
of him which made him double down and
work harder at being an electric guitar
player so you had the drums down pat I
just had really kind of figured out the
feet in the hands like early on and that
once I did that it was easy okay and
your current your current movie I hate
kids what's what's that all about for
those who want to consume something this
weekend's it's a fun family comedy it's
it's about a guy who's this novelist
he's a been a Playboy he doesn't want to
have kids of his own he meets the girl
of his dreams she doesn't want to have
kids
and then at the rehearsal dinner for the
wedding a thirteen year old guy walks in
and says you're my dad and it just
throws a wrench in all his plans for his
life so he's been connected to this kid
by a radio psychic played by Titus
Burgess who I completely believe is a
scam artist in this movie and then we go
on the road looking for this kid's mom
it's a very funny high jinks ensue
yada yada high road trip I love it it's
in theaters and on demand starting today
and we've got Andrew Savage coming in an
hour number three what timing and you
it's a trifecta of I'm sorry now in
terms of all the acting and that you
have done professionally and have been
around so called non pros who show up on
your set where was I in the world of the
non pros be very honest showing up and
performing in a cameo of I'm sorry
that's coming I believe on truTV next
week if I'm not mistaken what do you
think tom well I was very excited to get
to work with you I'm a big fan thank you
for saying that pre Hannah you did back
at you you did not disappoint you you
were great we got to do a little improv
at the top of our scene we did I thought
it was funny
you run over and give us the thing that
we don't want the end of the scene I
know it was fantastic then we got to
hate you the rest of the time and wait
till you hear there's Chris you'll see
part of this next hour when Andrea shows
up and we do the the clip I play a dad
at a birthday party okay where he and
Andrea show up at and the gift bag is
not a loot bag or any toy it's a
goldfish the parents I'm basically
handing them a bag of a problem because
they'll have to explain to their
children about death when the thing
actually dies that's right and the
entire episode is as good as it gets
yeah we just curse you the whole time
they do well it's fantastic great mm-hmm
so I think it's fun I thought you were
great and you know our kids actually go
to school together said oh no if we have
to work something out now we're number
three or something like that I think you
should return can we shoot it on a day
that's not 120 degrees by the way it was
the hottest day of the year it really
was
yeah over the summer hey before I let
you go I want to play the game start
bench cut that we play here on the Rich
Eisen show with you sir okay great
sounds like another game it is another
game Tom Everett Scott and start bench
cutter we gonna be quiet okay so you
have to start one bench one and cut one
okay it's essentially the game here best
name in Hollywood beside yours comprised
of three first names Neil Patrick Harris
mm-hmm Jamie Lee Curtis mm-hmm Sarah
Jessica Parker Wow
that's you muscles are also great start
one bench one and cut one Tom Everett
Scott okay I am going to I'm gonna start
Sarah Jessica Parker okay that's it is
that that one against the Vegas line on
that one I think Neil Patrick Harris was
the betting favorite okay
okay that's okay you stick with what
you're won I'm gonna bench Jamie Lee why
are you cutting your Patrick cuz cuz
it's time all of it
okay next one best hair beside you of
male co-stars you've worked with in your
career Ryan Gosling in la-la-land Ben
Affleck in boiler room Josh Duhamel and
brave town start bench cut three
incredible heads of lettuce right now I
know that look at Josh Duhamel come on
look at that right begging to be started
look I'm gonna happen he's lobbying for
the start in this photograph right there
I gotta be honest radio audience he is
right there just I think that's some
good do okay I think I'm gonna I'm gonna
bench RG my boy is that his name I call
him that
I'm game you know but we're pals and
then I'm gonna cut benefits
sorry ban so RG by the way the RG in my
life is Roger Goodell it's that is
actually you know what what people do
call him that's a funny but call him RG
arg the goods never to his face though
ever do people get upset with you
walking down the street thinking that
you actually kept Ron
sling and Emma Stone from getting
together in Long Island is that actually
I've been able to being the bad guy in
that movie my favorite story from that
is when I got cast in the movie I told
my neighbor Jamie because she was very
excited for me that I was gonna do this
movie and I I said well do you want me
to tell you what happens in the movie
and she says sure sure sure so I tell
her the whole story about Emma and and
Ryan Gosling being in love but at the
end they don't get together but when you
just when you think that she's married
and settled down with him the camera
pans and it's me instead of him and she
went no what did you do to celebrate the
20 seconds where you thought you were in
an oscar-winning film I was getting
ready with my wife to go to the
after-party we were watching it at home
like straightening my ties kind of
waiting to see and they wanted great
let's go is gonna be a great party and
then that happened where they didn't win
and I was just struck I didn't know what
to do it was kind of Numb and I looked
over and both my kids were filming me
like seriously guys so it's on a phone
somewhere fastened they didn't post it
but one next time you come here last one
last one for Tom Everett's got here
start bench cut start bench cut
fictional movie band that would have had
that would have the most success in
today's world the wonders from that
thing you do spinal tap from this is
spinal tap or still water from almost
famous
oh my guitar Everett Scott I got to
start the o-neders the audience I mean
if Captain Keaton the shrimp Shack
shooters were on there that have an
automatic start right I think I'm gonna
bench spinal tap because who doesn't
love spinal tap and then I'm gonna cut
Stillwater it's it because they're just
almost famous is that terrible is it
I'll show myself out hey man always
loved having you on come back anytime
you wish thank you he's congrats on all
your success I hear heads in theaters
and on demand today and also I'm sorry
which is just as hilarious as it gets
man thanks Congrats on being on that
Thank You good luck to your pabts have
fun in Atlanta and thanks for bringing 9
of
the green room and drop there's about
nine thousand okay one for every Tom
Brady Super Bowl appearance Wow yeah
baby
see and he's not a Masshole he says okay
that's a mic drop
Tom Tom E Scott on Twitter and the Tom
average got on Instagram
okay eight four four 200 for rich we'll
take your phone calls when we come back
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience